prends un prénom français ça veut dire
de la part de ses parents voilà je veux
rentrer dans votre communauté
je vous aime je veux adopter votre
histoire avec qui la presse que cet
argument vous convainc vous j'écoutais
eric que j'aime beaucoup comme personne
parce que c'est un gars qui a le goût du
débat d'idées et beaucoup de cultures
mais avec qui il le sait je suis
d'accord dans aller 1% ou 2% des cas et
je l'écoutais avec sourire parce que je
me disais l'animateur il va me passer la
parole tout de suite est-ce que c'est
compliqué de répondre à cette question
quand c'est compliqué en fait je
rappelle à vous peut-être les alors je
vous dis je vais vous dire ma position
mais je vais vous dire ma position je le
comprends je comprends ce qu'il veut
dire il est un enfant de l'hyper
assimilation il vient du constantinois
d'une famille juive en partie arabe dans
chez ses ancêtres donc il sait le prix
de la simulation et c'est vrai que dans
sa famille qui est une famille juive
d'algérie on n'aurait pas eu l'idée
probablement en tout cas à la génération
v rik de l'appeler ilan
voilà on n'aurait pas eu l'idée de lui
donner un prénom hébraïque ou you have
bon ok mais ce qu'oublie je pense dans
sa danse a dans sa fougue finkiel
chrétienne qui consiste au fond à
généraliser son cas personnel
ce qu'ils oublient zemmour c'est que on
peut aimer la france de toutes ses
fibres
on peut vibrer au sacre de reims comme à
la fête de la fédération en s'appelant
mohammed ou en s'appelant yasmina c'est
pas incompatibles surtout aujourd'hui
dans une france qui est de fête
multiculturelle je ne nie pas que le
multiculturalisme est une valeur mais
elle est de fait et pourquoi on ne
pourrait pas quand on s'appelle malek
malek boutih être un républicain
français impeccable c'est ridicule
malek boutih je veux dire y'a pas plus
république inclut enfin si y'a manuel
valls
voyez c'est deux garçons qui sont venus
de l'étranger l'un d'algérie l'aude
d'espagne qui portent chacun des prénoms
qui sont connotés par l'étranger et
pourtant c'est des gens qui peuvent nous
en remontrer en matière de lotion
républicaine et clément 6
donc là je trouve que la réflexion
d'eric comment dire elle n'est pas datée
elle signale l'auto référentialité de
sacré
iq il faut toujours faire très attention
quand on prend son cas personnel comme
exemple à généraliser
valentin de temporalité parce qu'on peut
sans doute s'appeler mohamed abd el
malek et adoré la république je suis
reconnaît et figurez vous que je suis à
la manoeuvre
il ya beaucoup de justement de français
musulmans qui aiment la république qui
publient des articles à mon idée à mon
initiative dans son clip c'est le
magazine closer que vous connaissez les
acheter soit un cumul sans me voyais pas
frapper mais que ça continue regardez
bien mais surtout c'est un problème de
temporalité parce qu'on peut s'appeler
mohamed et adoré la france mais est ce
que on peut adorer la france et appelé
son fils mohamed c'est les questions que
pose l exeo mort et ce n'est pas la même
après moi je ne sais pas il répond je
regrette c'est très compliqué et que
c'est un faisceau d'indicés
l'intégration et que ça ne tient pas
qu'à ça je voyage est une de mes amies
qui est française d'origine congolaise
est qui qui est à la fois très française
est très congolaises ont choisi vous
dise
mais là elle se marie et son mari va
payer une dot à sa famille parce que
telles sont les traditions congolaise et
une salle empêche absolument pas du tout
d'être très intégré ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est que parce
que vous mettez la photo de accepte
aussi je ne sais pas si les
téléspectateurs la voix je ne sais pas
si on fait référence au débat sur est ce
qu'il faut appeler ses enfants jean marc
ou plutôt que ma mère pour être
assimilée où est-ce qu'on fait référence
à ce clash ce buzz à l'effet lieu c'est
qu'avant je n'étais pas si ça leur dit
que c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
d'avancée simples humains passent et
plus je sais c'est la question que 5 et
arte vous composer l'équipe problème que
ce que l'on peut reprocher puisqu'il eu
de temps en fait des images que j'ai pu
voir et eu un temps où lui a dit votre
mère n'aurait pas dû vous appelez
absatou et vous leur ai dit vous appelez
corinne ça aurait été beaucoup mieux et
là tout le monde rigole tout le monde
trouvait ça très très très sympathique
deuxième temps il lui dit à lui dit vous
êtes une insulte vous ensuite et la
france et lui lui répond c'est votre
prénom qui est une insulte à la france
et c'est là que franchement c'est à mon
avis quelque peu importe que ce qu'on
pense sur le prénom aussi ou le prénom
ça c'était le la phrase abrasives qui
kidnappe le débat qui kidnappe la
réflexion en fait sur ce thème et je
trouve ça dommage je dépassais laquelle
on
on revient vous avez un point de vue là
dessus se fie aux gagnants écoutez le
débat est effectivement assez
désagréable et cette phrase est
épouvantable mais je pense surtout que
l'époque a changé et je vous rejoins
c'est à dire qu'en fait je pense que
eric zemmour qui est un jury d'algérie
voudrait que les musulmans de la
deuxième de la troisième voire bientôt
de la quatrième génération s'intègrent
et s'assimile avec un prénom français
faut savoir que les juifs d'algérie donc
sans doute le père et voir le grand père
d'eric zemmour avait deux prénoms c'est
un prénom hébraïque et un prénom
français et donc il y avait un prénom
hébraïque qui servait dans la communauté
pour les fêtes religieuses et pour les
fêtes familiales
et puis un nom un prénom français pour
montrer le signe d'assimilation donc
c'est ça qu'il aurait dû expliquer c'est
que finalement ça mon peuple et c'est
simplement que je pense qu'il aurait dû
expliquer cette nuance pour expliquer à
cette femme qui porte un prénom
compliqué peu compréhensible en france
en tout cas on peut avoir non pas une
double appartenance mais une image en
famille je dirais domestique et une
image un prénom donc plus républicain
pour s'intégrer dans la république parce
que je le dis toujours malheureusement
c'est la vérité il est vrai que certains
prénoms ne permettent pas de trouver du
travail facilement il est vrai que
certains prénoms exclus de la vie
sociale en france c'est encore une
réalité des faits est en train de
changer c'est en train de changer mais
encore aujourd'hui il y a moins de
mohammed qui trouvent du travail que des
jean-pierre ça reste une réalité que ce
soit le cas si vous lisez les articles
de philippe d'iribarne paraît dans le
figaro précisément les malheureusement
un homme très estimable mais totalement
démarqué par sociologues totalement
démarqué par sa critique disons ben
voyons des systématique des races
c'est pas du tout le cas je suis désolé
c'est important ce point est très
important parce que c'est ça c'est une
espèce de phrases qui re dit sans arrêt
dans les médias qui n'a aucun fondement
en l'occurrence c'était une une étude de
l'institut montaigne qui a été fait sur
des testings c'était voilà et il leur
dit c'est que les résultats de ces
testings donc il parle pas du slam et on
voit en fait que le problème n'est pas
tellement le prénom ni même
l'appartenance religieuse mais c'est
plutôt le côté pratique on quitte peut
constituer un frein ce que confirme
hakim el karoui d'ailleurs dans son
livre les femmes une région française
nationale serait vite en matière votre
opinion là dessus je ne trouve pas que
ce prénom afssap tôt ses farces et afssa
tout soit une insulte à la france ou à
la république personnellement je ne
trouve pas mais je voudrais revenir sur
les propos que vous avez passé d'eric
zemmour oui il regrettait cette a fait
quelque chose qui avait lieu avant 81
c'est à dire qu'avant 80 quand vous
alliez inscrire votre votre enfant on
vous et choisir les prénoms sont ceux
des étrangers dans le calendrier c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup
d'africains qu'ils acquittent était né
en le 14 juin et le fait la fête comme
fête nationale voilà est bon à partir de
on a on a changé ça alors c'est vrai et
c'est vrai que c'était et c'est vrai que
par exemple les juifs qui sont venus pas
seulement d'afrique de nom mais ceux qui
sont aussi venus d'europe centrale ont
fait un très grand effort pour prendre
des prénoms français pour voilà romain
gary et se sont parfaitement intégrés
l'intégration des juifs soit qu'ils
soient venus d'europe de l'est soit
qu'ils soient venus deux
de free de nord est un modèle
d'intégration et que c'est dommage moi
je pense qu'effectivement que c'est
dommage qu'on n'ait pas maintenu la
liste des prénoms du calendrier il ya
ceci dit une difficulté parce qu'il y
avait quand même et une difficulté donc
c'est pas un problème simple c'est que
il y avait des gens qui prenaient des
red et des prénoms républicain par
exemple des gens qui ont l'audace qui
appelait joffre comme le maréchal joffre
leurs enfants joffre dumazedier d'un
sociologue célèbre voilà alors
effectivement si vous avez quelqu'un qui
veut appeler son fils abdel qader
abdelkader c'est celui qui a fait la
guerre contre nous en algérie mais c'est
aussi celui à qui on a donné la grand
croix de la légion d'honneur et qui à
protéger les chrétiens à damas lorsqu'il
était et qui le deuxième en queue leu
leu deuxième anti embrassé sur la bouche
donc c'est le prêt d alors il ne faut
pas non plus si c'est vrai qu'il a de
notre ami notre ami zemmour a un peu
dépassé la mesure lorsqu'il a dit c'est
une insulte à la france
un peu comme alexis lacroix a peu à peu
dépassé la mesure lorsqu'il m'a dit que
la hongrie était totalitaire ses
promesses voici grand prince aujourd'hui
c'est mon jour
sur ce que sur ce que à 10 sur les
phrases que nous est proposée d'eric
zemmour il faut reconnaître qu'il a
raison que ça faisait davantage nation
également lorsque je suis nullement dire
toi mais comme je suis d'autre part
sinon on va y passer la nuit dehors
le criant sur ce que zemmour et crimée
mais le livre est très bon lire
notamment dans le passage puisqu'on y
fait allusion et on lire à vos pratiques
sont enfonce d'enfants d'algérie seront
500 articles de très belles paroles
d'une groupe d'anticiper sur ce sony
c'est parce que le r virulent mais moi
je le fais parce que la retirer votre
article était tout à fait intéressant je
laisse l'a dit le dernier mot à nos
internautes à anti mac qui nous dit les
gens doivent pouvoir choisir les prénoms
de leurs enfants point d'exclamation
alors que amir nous dit on ne doit pas
se contenter d'une francisation de
surface avec des prénoms
il nous reste très peu de temps pour
parler de la rénovation du grand palais
bâtiments emblématiques alors on va le
faire